hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to failure ah winner okay
welcome back to let's play gray 9 big oh
where are you yeah best what's a 7 yeah
I'm on a roll let's eat up to it not
cooking and I know all right
I thought I was gonna win there but no
okay it must be ah - yeah point Aust
winner i win it everything oh this looks
nice
I wonder what's gonna ruin it today this
looks downright Pleasant ah little
Poochie oh how nice
oh look no a nice painting of Sweden
land or whatever that is look ah got bad
again okey buck yup yeah this is nice
ah so nice just being here for a few
seconds our let's go back into insanity
yep that's insanity don't know what that
was all about maybe there was something
in there that I wasn't like click on I
don't know fusing come on oh maybe it's
like a brief glimpse of non insanity in
his life cuz obviously this guy's that
[ __ ] insane for obvious reasons
everyone has ah see you what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do what do
you do are you gonna do what are you
gonna do I got a drill I forgot about my
what are you gonna do what do you do
what are you gonna do oh just try Oh
mother ah yeah give me that I'm the
winner
not gonna port me I got no help
literally nothing I'm probably just [ __ ]
myself over I did I did I [ __ ] myself
over Oh got you um best Oh first what
was that I saw that what was that I saw
something
ah no yes so great ah okay I'm the best
reload my grill wait how do I reload my
room oh I get it
oh just automatically okay okay yes did
it I got no help but I did it does that
mean the revenge was sweet for only a
moment before the taste turn rotten in
my mouth I had acted on the part of
justice but under the guidance of many
lives not the ability to breathe to
think clearly how could I be expected to
reliably tell good from evil
my actions however well intended cannot
be you clearly when I am unable to tell
fact from fiction objective reality no
longer applies everything can be seen
from another clear anger
eventually I resurface from a fever
dreams I had blacked out myself back
home
yay they gave me health Oh what am i
doing what am i what the [ __ ] do you
what do you want yeah yeah ah wha what
then what are you
this is like a boss loss or something
whoa that close
oh yeah wait no yeah fine [ __ ] oh gosh
gonna die all right
okay there's obviously stuff here didn't
pick that up
did I I don't even know I can't even
tell Mario yeah yeah I got blown up
tickle yeah yeah what I thought okay I
saw another one what are you doing ah
[ __ ] [ __ ] you oh god why oh there I
go that's that's ghost I of course I
didn't handle that very well
okay so immediately I must go and search
for Umbro
[Music]
gimme gimme more amaura no no get away
get away you [ __ ] get away you stupid
stupid monster
I'll plenty of bullets get out of here
seriously are you you dance yeah one
down I'm just assuming I gotta get out
of here oh my god I swear I'm about to
die
I'm about to die all right there I go I
died from the babies I guess I don't let
them pile up like that but I get nope
not today
give me that give me your hand get out
of here
yeah you got cut up by the thingies whoa
whoa oh baby's too many babies okay was
that all of them that was all of them
right now
holy hell holy hell Holly now here's I'm
all beat fine so many of them what am I
supposed to do flip switch nope just die
instantly nuts dying instantly is good
too and there's so many of them ah
[ __ ] hell I swear the sky
oh my god what could I do mm I couldn't
even hit that one what the kids what is
this this is bull this bull man these
things are [ __ ] annoying oh my god
all right I got a I got a restart from
beginning here because I think I got a
like kill them make sure they don't like
build up like that you think that I
would be great about these eyes they
haven't even really been a problem
optional another one on this one oh my
god
I swear that is oculus that is just
ridiculous oh this is the wrong save -
oh no it's the right one no wait okay
I've got pretty good aim this ridiculous
got my ways swinging late oh hello
and I swear this like again I just
killed one of you oh my god okay alright
now I yeah I'm alright yeah already god
I don't even know what I'm supposed to
do after I kill all those big things
like seriously I'm looking around I'm
trying to figure it out but oh man this
is ridiculous
this is quite literally freaking
ridiculous get just kick
no no no again welcome back ago oh my
god the biggest [ __ ] I've ever seen
in my life
[ __ ] he's [ __ ] are you seeing this
[ __ ] this this is a disappointment I
hate to see games I'm assuming this is
the [ __ ] ending I hate to see games
end like this
they have such [ __ ] potential what
just what just hit me like black spots
I swear I'm heading right on
I killed a big one why don't you kill me
while you're at it oh this is bad idea
no no I said no no [ __ ] I'm almost out
of em yep there we go that's good
all right what's going on seriously what
am I made progress is this good is this
bad and I'm winning am i losing I don't
know what's up how did you get there I
don't know it's confusing
you the last one who are you where did
you come from why are you there what am
I gonna do about you why do I have so
many unanswered questions should I save
should I not okay oh oh
what okay I I think I did what I could
you did what you could what up you could
have done a lot better than murdering a
little girl that's for damn sure
once again I'm out of ammo and I'm out
of Wow how long has that been their home
what is going on I'm so confused
this guy's so beyond insane I don't even
understand it I don't even I don't even
know ward we were so happy so happy here
starting a new life life a fresh
beginning beginning our way past just
Jews Jenny you have to sit there and
watch it's nice to win my little buddy I
left you so many questions like jewelry
but now I can help you and help you
you'll find the true in the basement a
basement I don't want to find the truth
in the bed I'd rather not that's just oh
hello
one of Anita's dogs who was the little
girl that I murdered just I uh I don't
know okay apparently that was not the
end so I don't even know what to say
about that
yeah I probably just needed to learn to
play I probably just a giant noob and
just wasn't able to handle it
anyway so I'm all out of time for this
episode so thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part bye bye